yeah um anyway what are we talking about
will smith having too much poops yeah
yeah let's talk about that no i'm no i
[ __ ] no
enough
like i swear like
when this [ __ ] started with him and jada
like telling their sex life like i
thought it was like
like a weird pr thing of like
we need to let the young people know
you're still cool
you should tell them about a time you
did a threesome or you you should tell
them about the time you did acid you
know like
i thought it was like some weird like
relevancy thing where they're like no
let them know you know just because i'm
old i'm not washed man yeah and then
it's just turned into like what well
this is just to promote a book so you're
right it is a pr thing oh does he have a
book yeah it does have will opened up
about his fir right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah all this is a giant pr ploy that's
all it is let me see look at that that's
him holding his new book
and this is the same thing that every
celebrity does like this for their book
they write something that nobody knows
that is very clickbaity yeah and they go
to the pr agency and they're like let's
definitely use that for an article yeah
and then i mean this this is pretty
absurd though will smith opened up about
how we resorted to having rampant sexual
intercourse to deal with being cheated
on by his first girlfriend which led to
him developing a psychosomatic reaction
to having an orgasm
meaning he almost threw up he gagged and
almost vomited every time he came
that's brutal yeah
he's just like getting tough and
he's like no no no you got you got it
and slowed down she's like oh oh are you
are you going too much are you going to
don't tell me are you going are you
going to
are you going come yeah
yeah
um are you okay are you gonna vomit yeah
which one is it are you gonna come or
vomit i'm gonna i know both
his legs are squishing in her mind are
you liking this or is it bad i don't
know no she's like i'm gonna make him
yeah
i'm gonna make you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
now that's perverse
that's that happened in the first family
actually the hits are right on the top
of the head just [ __ ] flap
i'm gonna come what i'm gonna come
i'm gonna oh
bro what was the first
throw up episode like you know what i
mean there was that first one where he
nutted and then yeah
what was the timing yeah i don't know
like same time that's what i was just
thinking like was it what it was like a
little bit boston at the same you know
yeah
your boss didn't come
just [ __ ]
yeah
both both ends
exactly yeah i feel kind of bad for the
girl though because she'd be like is
that was it that bad no it was really
good but like you threw up like in a in
a hot way
i was so nauseous from how good you were
what does this actually mean does it
mean like you're sick with yourself for
having so much sex
yeah i don't know
we probably have to buy his book to find
out
okay i had sex with so many women and it
was so constitutionally
disagreeable to the core of my being
that i developed
like he felt like he was kind of like a
weird like
humble brag too
isn't it yeah oh man
after the first time i got cheated on i
went on a [ __ ] terror my guy yeah but
it was like so
it was so like contradictory to who i am
as a man which is like
you know family man but i was [ __ ]
out five times a day just like not me
but like i couldn't it wasn't me so i
just felt sick about it but i was still
[ __ ] there's a vicious cycle where i
would like wake up and [ __ ] and then the
thing is i respect women though
i respect women and i love women but i
was [ __ ] five hoes a day yeah
but it's like
five [ __ ] a day yeah and it made me
sick to my stomach because i respect
them so much i just wake up and [ __ ]
throw up and just
[ __ ] again and then throw up again like
[ __ ] again and throw up again i'm like
[ __ ] is it [ __ ] dinner already [ __ ]
so i try to eat something and i couldn't
keep it down because i just [ __ ] again
and then and this girl gave me the
craziest head that made me sick
made me sick that i could enjoy this
much head oh god damn was the best head
ever every day all day
but i couldn't do it i felt sick to my
stomach it felt so gross but i still did
it
i was so sick so sick
so sick to my stomach that i could just
receive that much top dude it was so it
just made me feel so sad
that i could lay that much pipe
and satisfy that many women oh maybe it
makes me want to puke just thinking
about it right now thinking about all of
i can make all those women squirt
think about all the [ __ ] i made come
it's just oh i just can't handle it
i mean so many [ __ ] come dude i just
so disgusting all that top i got
so yeah anytime i [ __ ] now i just bring
a barf bag so
you know that cleans it up pretty good
you imagine that he's [ __ ] some girl
and he pulls out like an american
airlines bag that he took from the plane
you go ride it with him from the plane
he just pulls out he's like just chill
[Laughter]
what do you do don't freak out
just it's
it's
it's just not fair what it's not fair
that i can [ __ ] this much
it's not fair to you she's like it was
great what do you mean i feel bad i feel
like this is actually some real drama
and we're just like making fun of it
yeah that's what we're doing
it is though right it's kind of a
um no [ __ ] that dude that is the
craziest sentence to say out loud
there's that's the only way we could
cope with a statement like that yeah
because after the laughter's over we
have to all go home and be like
[Music]
damn will smith had so much sex he threw
up
you know what i mean like that is gonna
he's inflicting trauma on people he
hasn't even realized it people are gonna
leave from this book feeling like i
haven't lived yeah
it's not fair that he exposed us to this
universe that he lives in where he's
like yes
hundreds of thousands of sexual partners
yeah but don't do that though because
it's so bad for you it was
constitutionally disagreeable with my
soul who i am inside
that i [ __ ] that many [ __ ] yeah
he's gonna you're just gonna feel bad
reading that [ __ ] yeah there's a dude
with a body count of like 400 that's
going to read this book and go damn i
haven't thrown up
i'm clearly not doing it enough damn
jesus
yeah
everyone's gonna
this is actually what's gonna push our
society into just
a sexually free society yeah
everyone's gonna read this book and be
like we must [ __ ] more
we must all experience thank you mr
smith it might be trauma but it's it's
funny trauma yeah
he's okay he's fine yeah he's got two
great kids yeah very good
yeah
yeah i thought there was another one oh
yeah yeah yeah well he's not famous it
doesn't doesn't matter you [ __ ]
dude
who's it trey trey yeah i wonder if trey
like heard these stories growing up and
he's like
i don't want anything to do with
hollywood yeah seems really bad for you
man i think i'ma just
i'm gonna just go sell cars yeah
that sounds like
something like a teenager says after
they smoke weed for the first time like
some made up like dude i got so high i
[ __ ] did a cartwheel
that doesn't happen when you're high man
yeah it does for me it does because i
was so high you weren't smoking the
right [ __ ] if you're not wanting to do a
cartwheel bro
oh yeah i [ __ ] so much this weekend i
threw up
dude you're definitely a virgin
do you think it's not true then no i
think it's true i bet you he told that
and there is like some weird kid that
talked about having this reaction in
high school and everyone clowned him for
being a virgin he's like will like he's
vindicated yeah
he he lost his virginity and then he
came to school and was like
dude i had sex i threw up i think like
having sex made me puke you've never had
sex bro literally you would love it shut
the [ __ ] up she's not fair that i get to
[ __ ] like this
do you think he knows all the time
do you think it's not fair to you
she's like but will i it was great what
do you mean it's just i'm like i'm i'm
not this dude you know
just like
what i'm gonna be sick again
that's that's what i was about to say
how was having sex with will do you
think he was good until the very end do
you think he nutted
some girl had her big o and they're
having a conversation and that's when it
hit him yeah
you're just so one second
what the [ __ ] what the hell i was just
trying to open up i know i just it's the
thought of the
the what
what the thought of what no
and then you can't tell her that you had
that you that you're vomiting because
you have too much sex yeah so you have
to just make something up and then just
yeah you stink
[Laughter]
why'd you puke uh your
uh
take a shower
change your shampoo it stinks
yeah bro
you